hide behind its own pawns Black's King  cannot hide behind its own Pawns  actually this end game when black  doesn't have his two pawns it should  still be a draw  um that was a really hard one to to hold  but even if black lost both of his pawns  it should still be fine for him because  he can give a bunch of checks  um this one should be a draw with best  play Yeah and I don't think Magnus can  risk it any further  the black kings in serious trouble if  white gets time to check  so yeah give another track for stacking  back  surely now they've tried long enough  both of them to get that win yeah  you can tell by the facial expression  he's he's done yeah that's the second  time and if he steps the king up and  it's over yeah after 84 moves it ends in  a draw between of the satoros and Magnus  Carlsen the world champion shakes his  head he wanted to win this game  desperately